[Musique]
bonjour Vincent capocanella merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité ce matin
nous accompagne pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu de la scène
saint membre du groupe Union centriste
on va parler de votre texte sur
l'ouverture à la concurrence des bus
franciliens dans quelques instants mais
d'abord l'actualité toujours du côté
d'Israël où Emmanuel Macron doit se
rendre demain c'est ce qu'à annoncé hier
soir l'élisé est-ce que ce déplacement
est trop tardif pour vous je crois que
c'est une bonne chose que le Président
de la République se rende sur place le
président américain vient de le faire
il y a beaucoup d'enjeux il y a une
émotion très forte il y a la question de
la sécurité d'Israël il y a la question
aussi du respect d'un certain nombre de
règles internationale la situation à
Gaza est extrêmement tendue chacun le
chacun le mesure et parler avec les
parties prenantes je crois que c'est une
bonne chose affirmer la voie de la
France qui doit être une voie de
condamnation du mouvement terroriste
Hamas et des atrocités qui ont été
commises euh mais aussi expliquer
comment on peut demain essayer de
trouver les voies pour éviter un
embrasement voilà il y a le Hamas qu'il
faut combattre clairement et puis
ensuite il faut être au côté de nos
compatriotes qui sont autagees euh de
l'ensemble des otages et affirmer une
voix qui est la voix de la France est-ce
que pour aider les otages et obtenir
leur libération il va falloir négocier
avec le hamass la position de la France
traditionnelle c'est de pas discuter
directement avec les mouvements
terroristes chacun a pu voir lors de la
libération qui est heureuse de deux
otages américains qui avaient un C
nombre de partenaires avec lesquels nous
pouvons discuter avec tatsunis on
discuté je crois que quand on est en
situation de défendre des compatriotes
qui sont aage les voies de la diplomatie
sont celle qu'on active et il faut le
faire en respectant nos principes mais
avec quand même le souci d'aider nos
compatriotes votre président de groupe
RV Marseille qui a posé la question il y
a quelques jours nos relations avec le
Qatar quand on voit le rôle du Qatar
dans la libération des otages et
notamment des otages américaines est-ce
que c'est le moment de se poser les
questions de nos relations avec le Qatar
je crois que on est dans une situation
qui est assez inextricable au proche au
Moyen-Orient et on voit bien que euh
tout enfin tout peut basculer euh le
Qatar a historiquement euh choisi
d'accueillir la partie politique euh du
du Hamas c'est effectivement quelque
chose qu'on peut condamner euh là-dessus
Hermé Marseille a justement posé la
question tout comme il a posé la
question du rôle de l'Iran et évidemment
le Hamas n'est pas arrivé tout seul à
commettre de de telles atrocités avec
une telle puissance donc ça fait partie
des des des points qu'il fallait qu'il
fallait effectivement souligner et il y
a dans la relation de la France avec le
Qatar une relecture à à faire bien sûr
il y a un débat qui aura lieu cet
après-midi à l'Assemblée nationale et
demain au Sénat sur la situation au
ProcheOrient en présence d'élisabe B
qu'est-ce que vous attendez du
gouvernement lors de ce débat d'abord je
souhaite que le le le débat au Sénat
traduise aussi la hauteur des enjeux
l'extrême difficulté l'extrême tension
no compatriotes on ça bien évidemment à
l'esprit en solidarité avec les
israéliens qui ont été attaqués euh mais
aussi euh bien évidemment le le sort des
otages est dans les dans les têtes
ensuite on a tous le souci que euh la
réplique les développements euh dans
dans dans la région notamment dans la
bande de Gaza reste dans les normes si
jeose dire euh terrible du droit
international en tout cas en situation
de en situation de guerre c'est une
guerre euh et ça et vous redoutez que ce
soit pas le cas qu'Israël aille trop
loin il faut réaffirmer la position de
la France et je crois que c'est une
bonne chose là-dessus respect du droit
international euh les les crimes de
guerre les crimes ça ça ça doit être
combattu là-dessus même si Israël doit
assurer sa sécurité alors je souhaite
qu'il y ait un débat serein au Sénat et
qu'on soit la hauteur de l'enjeu parce
qu'on voit bien que c'est un secteur
stratégique et tout ceci peut se
traduire par des enchaînements qui sont
effectivement mortifères et voilà il y a
un risque de conflagration dans dans la
région on voit bien aussi les risques
économiques qui sont sont qui sont
présents pour la marche du monde
globalement et puis chacun mesure aussi
que y compris en France il peut y avoir
des répliques malheureusement nous
sortons d'une période dramatique
l'assassinat du Professeur Bernard ça
nous montre bien que sans faire un lien
direct il y a comme dit le ministre de
l'Intérieur une forme d'atmosphère et
donc tout ceci doit être débattu et
débattu pour fixer les principes pour
inviter le gouvernement effectivement à
tenir la barre dans la relation avec la
région ok en solidarité avec
Israël mais en réaffirmant nos principes
clairement sur le droit international en
solidarité avec les otages qui est la
première préoccupation que nous devons
avoir je crois mais
aussi en tirant aussi de conséquences il
y a un djihadisme d'atmosphère et il y a
un djihadisme concret malheureusement on
le voit avec ce terrible assassina à
race alors justement le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui a de nouveau affiché sa
fermeté hier c'était en Une du journal
du DI dimanche sur le projet de loi
immigration qui arrive au Sénat le 6
novembre fermeté pour que ce texte
permette d'expulser les radicalisés vous
le suivez sur cette ligne dure écez moi
je pense que à chaque fois il y a un
temps pour l'émotion lorsqu'il y a des
des des attentats de ce type là qui
marquent beaucoup la communauté
enseignante qui marque la communauté
éducative qui marque le pays et après il
faut savoir tirer les tirer les leçons
le le risque c'est toujours le même
c'est-à-dire que dans la première phase
tout le monde se réunit après on se
divise sur les solutions et puis
finalement tout ceci passe parfois un
petit peu au deuxième plan beaucoup de
choses ont été faites il y a eu
renforcement des services de
sécurité la la la DGSI et la DGSE mène
mène une guerre sans merci contre le
terrorisme beaucoup d'attentats sont
déjoués maintenant il y a un problème de
moyen juridique aussi pour arriver à
expulser des délinquants il y a une
question qui nous faut trancher c'est
comment on peut lorsqu'il y a des
soupçons de radicalisation qui sont
étayés comment arriver à des expulsions
et PU puis il y air com maise estce
qu'il faut aboutir à un compromis coûte
que coûte sur ce texte moi je souhaite
qu'il y ait les voie d'un travail en
commun dans l'intérêt du pays on peut
pas dire à la classe politique on
attendra dire à no compatriotes qu'on
attendra 3 ans pour la prochaine
élection présidentielle les choses ne se
règlent pas au stade d'élection
présidentielle les choses se règlent au
Parlement avec la loi et il faut une loi
efficace alors deux choses là-dessus il
n'y a pas de honte à trouver des
compromis si ces compromis sont
exigeants sur des bases claires il
s'agit de se donner les moyens de mieux
défendre nos compatriotes d'une part et
d'autre part de contrôler l'immigration
aussi tout en réussissant l'intégration
c'est ça le le triptique et puis mais
mais juste sur quoi le compromis parce
qu'on sait qu'il y a un gros point de
divergence ici au Sénat entre leslr et
le gouvernement mais aussi entre leslr
et le centrist et ce fameux article 3
sur le titre de sesjour sur les métiers
en tension hier Gérald armmanin dans le
Journal du dimanche il semble faire
passer au second plan cet article dit
que l'heure est grave il faut qu'on
trouve des compromis sur des choses pas
centrale alors cet article 3 3 c'est
celui qui dispose que un certain nombre
d'étrangers qui sont en situation de
travailler en France bien que étant sans
papier puisse dans une certaine mesure
être être régularisé la question c'est
de pas créer d'appel d'air et en mê
temps on entend aussi les chsentreprises
qui nous disent qu'ils ont besoin de
main d'œuvre bon ça je pense qu'il ne
faut pas créer d'appel d' je suis sur
l'idée moi qu'il ne faut pas créer
d'appel d' du l'est clairement il y a
des voies possibles ou réglementaires ou
la circulaire Vals pour du cas par cas
et parfois régler ce genre de situation
il faut le faire avec humanité mais
fermeté je crois que c'est la logique de
fermeté quand même qui doit prévaloir de
mon point de vue en tout cas et puis je
veux dire également autre chose c'est
qu'on a un sujet qui est ce qu'on
appelle les juste fermeté ça veut dire
que c'est pas grave pour vous si cet
article ne figure pas dans le texte je
je pense que ça ça n relève pas
forcément du législatif et que il faut
rester dans le cas par cas mais nous
devons veiller à ne pas donner le signal
que la France peut accueillir plus
qu'elle nana les moyens et c'est le
signal que donne cet article et bien le
risque c'est celui-là vous êtes plutôt
sur la ligne des LR vous je suis sur une
ligne de fermeté personnel donc pas
forcément sur la ligne de V gr mon
groupe a affiché que ça ça n'était pas
forcément du du domaine législatif un
donc ça veut dire qu'un compromis vous s
possible comprom je veux dire simplement
qu'il un travail de fond aussi une
réflection de fond qu'il nous faut
ouvrir qui est la fameuse question des
des des obligations de quitter le
territoire français nos compatriotes à
juste ti ne comprennent pas que dès lors
que l'autorité judiciaire euh et
l'autorité ou l'autorité administrative
décide que un ressortissant d'un pays
étranger doit quitter le pays on y
parviennent pas il y a un sujet de droit
européen il y a un sujet de négociation
européenne là-dessus et il faut que nous
avancions ça me paraît un point majeur
quand même pour l'avenir de régler cette
questionl un dernier mot là-dessus le 12
décembre le texte de révision
constitutionnelle des républicains sera
à l'ORD du jour il veut permettre le
référendum sur l'immigration mais aussi
faire que le droit national prime sur le
droit européen et c'est contraire
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous voterez
cette révision moi je je ne suis pas
dans l'idée que le droit national et le
droit européen doiv doivent être opposé
je pense que nous avons une situation
nouvelle et qu'il faut en tirer les
leçons avec nos partenaires européens et
que le droit européens doit évoluer donc
non à la révision de je vais regarder le
texte clairement mais ma position à ce
stade est celle-ci un mot sur ce qui
s'est passé ce weekend dans le Tarne
autour du projet d'autoroute entre
castre et Toulouse il y a eu des
manifestations puis tentative de uction
d'unezad le gouvernement est intervenu
rapidement pour la démanteler il a eu
raison je crois qu'il faut toujours
respecter la loi il y a des formes
juridiques pour contester des projets
qui sont des projets déclarés d'intérêt
public et on ne peut pas comme ça
accepter que des mouvements décident par
la force d'investir des lieux d'arrêter
des procédures voilà ensuite je mesure
aussi ce que c'est que le désenclavement
et le fait que en zone rurale mais aussi
parfois en zone urbaines curieusement ou
par par manque de transport ou par
manque de liaison routière on puisse se
sentir coupé des emplois et on se puiss
se sentir déclassé doncà l'aspiration de
certains territoires dès lors qu'elle se
passe dans les formes juridiques
habituelles à au désenclavements doit
être entendu après la vraie question
c'est comment on fait la décarbonation
de l'économie comment trans écie est-ce
que c'est aussi ce que disent les
opposants est-ce que c'est encore le
temps de tels travaux dans ces temps
d'écologie est-ce que il faut encore
faire de tels travaux pour laisser la
place à la voit
quel est votre avis on ne fera pas la
transition écologique par la force et
par l'absence de respect du droit voilà
c'est ça ma position et il y a des
débats là-dessus il y a des projets qui
ont été arbitrés dans ce caslà il faut
les mener à bien après la question c'est
la place de la voiture qui bien sûr
pollue mais il faut savoir ce que c'est
que vivre en zone rurale et avoir le
sentiment que tout se passe en métropole
parce que on peut y accéder et parce
qu'il y a l'emploi parce qu'il y a les
transports et d'avoir le sentiment de
déclassement en zones rurale et c'est
aussi il faut l'entendre on va continuer
à parler des transports transport
francilien fin 2024 les bus franciliens
jusque là gérés par la RATP seront
soumis à concurrence vous avez rédigé
une proposition de loi pour faciliter le
processus et éviter qu'il ne fasse des
perdants on va voir les détails de votre
texte avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Alex
[Musique]
poussa bonjour Alex bonjour ran bonjour
Vincent capocanella bonjour et Alex les
sénateurs débattent donc cet après-midi
de la proposition de loi de Vincent
capocanella sur l'ouverture à la
concurrence du réseau de bus en
Île-de-France que va apporter ce texte
dans cette mise en concurrence qui a été
décidé depuis longtemps ah oui vous avez
raison Rian cette ouverture à la
concurrence des bus d'Île-de-France elle
a été décidée il y a plus de 15 ans avec
un règlement européen acté en 2007 sur
le principe de l'ouverture à la
concurrence des transports publics le
calendrier a été fixé par une loi de
2009 les modalités pratiques ont été
défin elle par une loi de 2019 avec un
objectif d'ouverture à la concurrence
effectif fin de 2024 alors à quoi sert
cette nouvelle loi et bien à régler les
derniers détails d'une réorganisation de
très grande ampleur regardez hein cette
ouverture à la concurrence de ce réseau
de bus francilien qui actuellement est
est dirigé par la RATP he la Régie
autonome des transports parisien et bien
cela va concerner 19000 salariés 300
lignes 308 lignes de bus et 4500 bus
c'est colossal et cette proposition de
loi et bien elle sécurise encore un peu
plus sur le plan social les salariés de
la RATP qui devront être transférés dans
d'autres entreprises ils n'auront pas de
changement de lieu de prise de poste ils
continueront à travailler dans le même
dépôt de bus le transfert de salariés se
fera d'abord sur la base du volontariat
avant d'être ajusté aux besoins
d'effectifs de l'entreprise qui aura
remporté le marché public on le rappelle
hein c'est la région Île-de-France qui
gère et finance ce réseau de transport
franilien via l'établissement public
Île-de-France mobilité et la Présidente
de la Région Île-de-France Valérie pcrè
qui a été auditionnée par les sénateurs
et bien elle veut aller encore plus loin
dans cette stratégie de sécuriser sur le
plan social les salariés de la RATP on
l'écoute
île-de-fance mobilité imposera aux
nouveaux opérateurs de maintenir les
conditions sociales dont bénéficient
aujourd'hui les agents de la RATP c'est
ce de France mobilité demandera dans ses
appels d'offre aux nouveaux opérateurs
ce qui permet évidemment de
tranquilliser des agents notamment sur
des régime de retraite qui sont un peu
spécifiques et cetera et enfin noter que
le calendrier de cette ouverture à la
concurrence a été assoupli prévu fin
2024 elle pourra finalement être
effective entre début 2025 et fin 2026
et donc s'éloigner un peu de la période
des Jeux olympiques de l'été prochain
Vincent capo canela ce texte donc
sécurise davantage les salariés de la
RATP et reporte assouplit le calendrier
d'ouverture à la concurrence des
transports de franilien est-ce que la
principale raison de ces ajustements
c'est une une peur d'une grève pendant
les j 2024 alors alors cette proposition
de loi fait suite à une concertation qui
a été menée par Monsieur baayi et grossé
et qui ont entendu non seulement
l'exploitant sortant la RATP qui sera
d'ailleurs candidate sur les 13 lots
j'imagine qui vont être mis en
concurrence mais aussi a entendu le
corps social les syndicats les
opérationnels île-de-fance mobilité il y
avait un certain nombre de d'obstacles
qu'il fallait lever il nous fallait
permettre que cette mise en concurrence
se passe bien bien pour les voyageurs il
s'agit d'améliorer aussi la qualité de
service parfois de s'interroger en tout
cas sur le service qu'on offre sur
chacun des lots et puis également il
s'agissait de régler des problèmes
sociaux importants euh et évidemment la
date qui était celle du 31 décembre 2024
n'était pas la meilleure juste après les
Jeux Olympiques pour permettre que la
bascule de tous les lots en même temps
ait lieu avant le 31 décembre ça
semblait difficile donc on a choisi de
détendre un peu le calendrier de
permettre qu'il ait un temps de
discussion avec tout le monde et ça a
permis ce texte là que je présente euh
en collectif et je je je souhaite qu'il
a il est le débat à la hauteur des
enjeux il ne s'agit pas de décider de l'
la concurrence vous l'avez très bien
rappelé elle est cette décision a été
prise il y a 16 ans maintenant donc il
s'agit de la rendre possible et de faire
que ça se passe bien pour tout le monde
les voyageurs mais aussi les salariés il
faut prendre en compte un certain nombre
d'acquis sociaux et ça sécurisera aussi
d'ailleurs les potentiels opérateurs
entrant oui parce que quand on entend le
discours de Valéri pcres qui est très
bienveillant sur ce régime spécial des
salariés de la RATP qui et bien final
contredit peut-être un petit peu le
discours qu'elle avait quand elle
défendait une réforme des retraites et
bien assez stricte et une suppression
des régimes spéciaux finalement ça
montre qu'il y a bien cette peur d'une
greffe pendant les Jos ça montre
simplement que il y a un statut
dérogatoire pour le personnel de la RATP
et qu'il faut le prendre en compte et
ensuite vous l'avez rappelé euh la loi
prévoyait qu'on transférait les lignes
de bus et ça aurait amené à ce qu'à peu
près 2000 chauffeurs de bus machinistes
comme on dit la RATP aurait dû changer
de dépôt de centrebus euh et donc
c'était une désorganisation ensuite il y
a un sujet c'est que parfois il y aura
des surffectifs sur certaines lignes
parfois il y en aura pas dans d'autres
il faudra combler et donc il y a un
sujet d'appel au volontariat tout cela
il fallait le traiter à l'époque on a
fixé notamment au moment de la loi
d'orientation sur les mobilités des
princible notamment ce qu'on appelle le
sac àados social ok euh donc un d'acquis
sociaux qu'il faut garder euh mais euh
en même temps on s'est rendu compte
après qu'il y avait des des points
majeurs vous l'avez rappelé il y a 1300
arrêt Debs par exemple il y a 4800 euh
bus et tout ceci va être transféré euh
et euh ça suppose un une infinie euh
précaution aussi et un certain nombre de
détail pour que ça réussisse euh l'idée
c'est de passer les lots un par un et
pas tous ensemble et se donner les
moyens pour que ça réussisse je veux
dire deux choses simplement pour
terminer un le bus a une place
considérable chez nos concitoyens euh en
zone urbaine mais en zone rurale aussi
euh ça permet des C de proximité euh ça
permet pour ceux qui ont des problèmes
de mobilité de voyager plus facilement
qu'en train ou qu'en métro euh et c'est
aussi la vie euh dans nos dans nos
villes donc c'est le quotidien des
Franciliens comme c'est le quotidien des
Français en province ce type de mise en
concurrence se pratique régulièrement
tous les 5 ans et ça marche il s'agit de
faire qu'on on réussisse à le faire à la
RATP aussi alors sachant qu'on verra
après euh qui sont euh les candidats et
euh comment tout ceci est exploité mais
euh l'île-de-fance doit réussir ce
passage à à la concurrence et ça marche
vous le dites cette mise en concurrence
est-ce qu'on est vraiment sûr que ça va
améliorer euh la qualité du réseau le
quotidien des usagers ou est-ce que fait
partie d'un dogme libéral qui voudrait
que la concurrence entre le privé c'est
mieux que le monopole public oh il y a
pas de dogme là-dedans l'idée simplement
c'est de se reposer la question au stade
des appels d'offres pour réfléchir à la
qualité de service pour se donner des
indicateurs ça a été fait en grande
couronne il faut que la petite couronne
et Paris réussisse aussi à le faire
merci Alex à tout à l'heure à tout à
l'heure on parlera d'un certain Gérald
armanant et ce sera s dans le club on va
continuer à parler transport on va aller
retrouver Jacques Paquier directeur de
la rédaction du journal du Grand Paris
bonjour JAC merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous on reste sur cette question
transport mais vous allez nous parler du
RB c'est notamment le R qui dessert les
aéroports tout à fait absolument mais on
va continuer de parler de qualité du du
service vous le savez monsieur capo
canelas un rapport vient d'être mis à à
Valérie PCR sur le
RB qui à la demande de Valérie PCR et
donc sont pointer de nouveau un matériel
vieillissant une baisse de la
ponctualité les ce qui le million qui le
prend qui le prend chaque jour est au
courant et ce rapport pointe notamment
un trop gros nombre d'acteurs Transilien
RATP sncn SNCF réseau est-ce que
monsieur le sénateur vous pensez qu'une
une meilleure coordination des acteurs
qui fait partie des pistes de ce rapport
suffira à résoudre le le problème n'y
a-t-il pas tout simplement trop
d'acteurs et ne faut-il pas finalement
en réduire le nombre sachant que ce ce
même problème risque de se poser avec la
gestion du du Grand Paris Express dans
quelques
années alors pour le Grand Paris exprès
je pense que il y aura une unité
d'exploitation hein chaque ligne est
mise en concurrence d'ailleurs
actuellement et euh il y aura une
gestion unifiée la difficulté
effectivement du RERB c'est qu'on se
retrouve avec une partie du réseau RATP
une partie SNCF et que au fil de ce
rapport on découvre qu'il y a encore des
sujets d'harmonisation euh pour le
quotidien de ceux qui emempointent la
ligne B il y a toujours un risque
lorsque vous av un rendez-vous important
il faut prendre beaucoup de marge vous
avez toujours le risque de d'un arrêt
d'une interruption euh voilà je dis
quelqu fois que j'ai raté deux
commissions mix paritaires parce que
j'étais dans le tunnel du Châtelet à
l'époque euh bon c'est quand même
quelque chose de compliqué alors c'était
des commissions mix paritaires dont je
savais qu'elles allaient échouer mais
quand même euh c'est toujours très
désagréable et pour pour le quotidien
celui qui a une épreuve euh
universitaire à passer par exemple un
examen celui qui va euh pour un
rendez-vous médical enfin voilà il y a
plein de de situations qui sont quand
même très très très difficiles alors
globalement tout cela doit s'améliorer
je salue l'intiative de la présidente de
la région de demander ce rapport alors
c'est pas un de plus c'est un rapport
qui est quand même assez concret je je
je l'ai survolé rapidement je vais
regarder mieux encor voilà mais je pense
qu'il faut maintenant y arriver à vous
poser une question implicitement c'est
est-ce qu'il faut choisir entre RATP et
SNCF ça se joue pas non plus comme ça
comme dirons-nous hein parce qu'il y
aurait aussi des inconvénients à faire
que l'un exploite le réseau de l'autre à
certains endroits mais il faut vraiment
que on s'inscrive dans dans dans quelque
chose de de positif pour cette ligne B
il y aura et malheureusement là aussi il
y a un décalage des livraisons de rames
dans le futur qui vont améliorer les
choses mais voilà je je pense que
maintenant il faut trouver des mesures
concrète supplémentaire et c'était le
sens de la demande de Madame PC et ja
vous avez une autre question sur les CIN
autour de l'organisation des Jeux
Olympiques notamment sur la question de
la sécurité tout à fait Oriane David
Douillet dans un journal du
dimanche dit qu'il faut DS à présent
réfléchir à un plan B notamment il parle
de la cérémonie d'ouverture qui est
prévue sur la scène en disant si la
situation internationale vous en parliez
de tout de suite ne s'améliorait pas il
y aurait un risque et qu' et on on ne
pourrait pas finalement organiser cette
grande cérémonie festive qui est prévue
sur la scène vous vous partagez ces ces
ces inquiétudes monsieur capo canelas je
crois que c'est dans la tribune dimanche
euh qui estant des journaux du dimanche
mais qui est pas le joural du dimanche
je je bon moi je veux dire David
dououillet est une voix autorisée
évidemment depuis le départ cette
manifestation cette cérémonie
d'ouverture pose question pose débat euh
le sujet ne pourra pas rester dans une
phase comme ça alternative oui non tout
le temps il y a eu une décision qui a
été prise il faut faut peut-être
réévaluer si dans le contexte notamment
de
terrorisme cette cette manifestation ne
prend pas trop d'effectif à un instant
donné euh donc ne pas la faire en
extérieur mais envisager de la faire
dans un stade il faut il faut sans doute
se reposer la question ok mais euh en
même temps nos forces de l'ordre ont
aussi besoin qu'on leur donne un cap
clair là-dessus voilà la France la
France a envie de de montrer au monde
entier que que que Paris c'est beau que
la scène est formidable que nous sommes
un écin de de moner t noous atout mais
c'est pas moment en avons-nous les
moyens bon c'est c'est une c'est une
bonne question bien évidemment VO mais
je que je veux dire c'est que il faudra
quand même fixer un cap clair
aujourd'hui c'est cette cérémonie là
telle qu'elle a été envisagée on pourra
pas changer non plus tous les de mois
merci merci Jacques paquet d'avoir été
avec nous la Une du journal du Grand
Paris c'est le Grand Paris terre de
tournage très prisé c'est à la Une du
journal du Grand Paris cette semaine
merci beaucoup Jacques d'avoir été avec
nous un dernier mot politique pour
terminer Vincent capocanella puisque les
européennes approchent ce sera au mois
de juin hier Hervé Marseille qui est
votre président de groupe mais qui est
aussi le président de l'UDI a dit
envisager une alliance entre l'UDI et
renaissance pour les européennes donc la
majorité présidentielle vous êtes
favorable écoutez je pense que c'est un
débat européen et que ce qui est naturel
c'est que les
Européens se retrouvent sur les mêmes
positions à ce stade là c'est ce qu'a
dit Marseille hier donc oui à une liste
avec Renaissance ça peut être une liste
qui rassemble tous les Européens
évidemment Renaissance est un grand mais
tous les Européens c'est large est-ce
qu'il faut qu'
deslr a moi je pense que euh dans dans
le climat actuel international dans le
climat de compétition aussi euh il faut
que l'Europe s'affirme se transforme
soit au côté de nos compatriotes et que
tous les Européens doivent porter ce ce
message là donc ça peut être avec DLR ça
peut être aussi avec avec Renaissance
bien évidemment bon qui est le mouvement
le plus important européen en France
aujourd'hui non mais ça veut dire qu'il
faut une grande liste LR Renaissance UD
je je suis pas certain que lesr a envie
d' venir quand même mais vous c'est ce
que vous souhaitez les Européens
ensemble merci merci Vincent capocanela
d'avoir été notre invité